ومن بين كل الاخبار عن الزلزال والدول
اللي اعلنت تضامنها وتعاطفها مع المتضررين
من هذه الكارثه الماساويه طلعت شعري لابدو
الفرنسيه صاحبه التاريخ الطويل في
الرسومات الكاريكتيريه الجدليه واللي
بتتهم كثير من الاحيان بانها مسيئه طلعت
الصحيفه اليوم برسم جدلي جديد حقيقه اقل
ما يوصف انه يعني بدون احساس والرسم عامل
حاله من الاستنكار حول العالم تجاه
الصحيفه فالصحيفه سخرت في الزلزال او صخره
من الزلزال في رسمها الالكتروني اليوم
وبعد ساعات بس من وقوع الزلزال المدمر
فنشرت رسم في دمار وانقاض وعنونته زلزال
تركيا وكتبت تحتها لم نضطر حتى لارسال
دبابات المقصود طبعا واضح تمني الدمار
لتركيا وانه ما في داعي يحاربوها او
يرسلوا دبابات لتدميرها لانه خلص او لانه
خلاص الزلزال دمرها الانتقادات والاستنكار
نزلت على الصحيفه من كل مكان في حرفيا من
مشاهير مواطنين سياسيين وغيرها واسمها
تحول الترند حول العالم وعلى فكره منتقدي
الصحيفه منهم كثير ناس سبق وتضامنوا معها
لما تعرضت لهجمات من متطرفين